the FBI tonight taking another look at
the Clinton Foundation searching for
evidence the foundation may have taken
donations brace yourselves
in return for political favors trace
Gallagher has more on that story he
joins us tonight hey trace hey Tucker
Fox News has learned the US Attorney's
Office and FBI have been looking into
the Clinton Foundation for months
they're focused mainly on pay to play
politics and we're told the key witness
was interviewed in December dealing
specifically with any comparisons
between donations to the Clinton
Foundation and government actions while
Hillary Clinton was Secretary of State
that's the first investigation there is
also Hillary Clinton's private email
server the hill has now published a
report featuring former FBI director
James Comey 'he's original draft on the
investigation which uses the term gross
negligence and says there was evidence
Clinton committed a felony anti-trump
FBI agent Peter Strahm
reportedly softened the language in
commis draft so Clinton could avoid
criminal charges the DOJ is exploring
whether to reopen the probe the Justice
Department is also asking FBI agents to
explain evidence gathered in the now
dormant uranium one investigation the
DOJ is deciding if a special counsel
might be needed uranium one is the 2010
transaction where the Obama
administration allowed the sale of US
uranium mining facilities to Russia's
state-run energy giant the Hillary
Clinton led State Department was among
the nine US agencies that approved the
deal finally there's a potential probe
into allegations the Obama
administration tried to secure the Iran
nuclear deal by ending a federal
investigation into the Iranian backed
terror group Hezbollah but ending the
investigation reportedly led to
Hezbollah trafficking hundreds of
millions of dollars of cocaine into the
u.s. and building up their base of
terror Hillary Clinton was Secretary of
State at the time the Clintons claimed
these are all efforts by Trump to divert
attention from Robert Muller's special
counsel Tucker trace Gallagher thanks
outrace congressman Matt gates as a
Republican represents the state of
Florida and joins us to any Congress
thanks coming up
so I don't know if you can hear me
congressman but if you can't gotcha
target just heard excellent thanks so
the Clinton people are saying look you
know Hillary Clinton has been a private
citizen for a long time she's been out
of politics in effect for a year why now
what's the significance of these do you
think for the rest of the country there
may have been acts that occurred at the
State Department as a consequence of
bribes paid to the Clinton Foundation
which are creating an ongoing security
concern for the United States of America
Tucker take for example that the
Hezbollah story you just mentioned it's
not just cocaine that's being trafficked
you've got Hezbollah working in common
cause with narco traffickers in South
America to move opium to move heroin to
move people into the United States and
the investigation that was going on to
degrade these networks to degrade the
collusion between Hezbollah and South
American narco traffickers was smothered
by people at the Justice Department and
there is a suspicion that the State
Department led by Hillary Clinton had a
role in limiting the American people's
access to information about Hezbollah
being funded and their operations in
this country because they wanted the
Iranian nuclear deal so bad they didn't
want us focusing on the fact that Iran
has funded over a hundred mosques in
South America to recruit people and then
to send them to the United States to do
harm so that's one one of the
investigations into that and it does
seem if if true first of all it's a bit
hard to defend but second it has obvious
national security implications for this
country tell us about the investigation
into the extent we know much about it
into the Clinton Foundation well the
accusation is that the Clinton
Foundation was merely a money-laundering
operation where people paid in order to
have access to the State Department and
there were notations on particular
documents and bids where people would
write fo be friend of Bill which means
those were donors to the Clinton
Foundation and as a consequence they
were given special treatment that's the
type of thing that we have to know about
now not to exercise some revenge on a
defeated presidential candidate but to
ensure that we don't have people right
now
thing as vendors on behalf of the United
States of America not as a consequence
of their merit or what they can do but
because their friends and potentially
donors to the Clinton Foundation yeah
well I mean that was that whole
operation was false from day one
obviously why is it taking so long to
get these investigations underway you
know we've been calling for this for
over five months twenty members of the
House Judiciary Committee sent a letter
to attorney general session saying that
we've got to look into these things
because of the ongoing security concerns
and finally now we have Hillary Clinton
dealing with investigations cascading
down on her like it's a bomb cyclone I
think the day is coming soon Tucker when
we'll be sending an I'm with her t-shirt
to Hillary Clinton's cell mate yeah I
mean you think that she is criminally
exposed potentially absolutely look if
people were taking bribes and then as a
consequence of those bribes engaging in
actions that they would not otherwise be
engaging in that is a crime you cannot
do that in the United States of America
and we've got to go now and remedy the
consequences take for example the
subject of your show tonight the opioid
problem if you had people trafficking
and would have been found out otherwise
we've got to now go back and remediate
the harm that the Clintons caused this
country
tungsten Medicaid Sephora thanks for
joining us tonight
appreciate it Thank You Tucker